سنعرض الان هذه المقابله التي اجرتها قناه
كان العبريه مع قائد الكتيبه الثال ع في
لواء
جولاني المحاربين الذين خرجوا من السجاعيه
بعد ايام طويله من حرب صعبه وقتال عنيف
ويستعدون للمرحله التاليه من القتال ونقول
مساء الخير سجن عمري قائد دوريه
جولاني مساء الخير ويف
انت جيده نحن نتحدث من ان نسال على
احوالكم نرى جنودكم من
الخلفيه يستعدون وراء وهم وراء النيران
كيف بعد كل هذا الوقت كان الوضع جيد جدا
وخرجنا بعد فتره طويله منذ السابع من
اكتوبر وفتره طويله من الحرب ايضا كانت
هناك فترات را قصيره في الحرب وايضا وفتره
توقف ومن اجل ونحن نتجه ال ماذا تعملون
بعد ان تخرجون بعد هذه الوقت الطويله
تنامون تتصلون بالبيت مع الام او الاب او
الصديقه المهم نحن نحن مع الهاتف ومن اجل
ناخذ الهاتف
ونتصل
وايضا هكذا نحصل على معلومات قليله من
الراديو وايضا كنا نحصل على موت قليله من
الراديو وايضا نحصل على المعلومات عن طريق
الهاتف والعائلات نقول لهم سلاما نحن نسمع
دائما هذه الكلمات الاخيره التي يقولها
الناطق بلسان شش الدفاع انكم تقضون على
البنى
التحتيه لحماس في الشجاعيه ماذا ماذا يعني
ذلك من ناحيه عملياتكم ماذا تلتقون هناك
يوما
بيوم قبل كل شيء كتيبه الشجاعيه هي كتيبه
لحماس من الدرجه الاولى الاحترافيه كل كل
السكان في منطقه الشجاعيه يقدمون من اجل
الارهاب مدارس ورياض اطفال وايضا هناك ضد
الساميه
وايضا
الارهاب لا يوجد بيت الا موجود فيه ارهاب
من الجهاد الاسلامي وحماس كل بيت هناك
سلاح واسلحه ومخربين ومن اجل ان نتحول الى
القتال في الرمال ومن اجل ان نفكك قواعد
حماس هناك ان نقضي على الاعداء ايضا نجد
فتحه نفق فتحه نفق اخرى التي تربط بين
المنازل
وعليه ما دفعناه من اثمان كان كبيرا وما
وماذا بشان المخطوفين في هذه اللحظه
الصعب
ايمكن ان يك هذا
ين موجود هناك خطف كيف كان شعوركم في هذه
الحاله في احد الليالي المحاربون فتحت
الراديو ونظرت عن طريق الشباك
ورايت الثلاثه مخطوفين الذين رفعوا الرايه
البيضاء وكان هناك نقاش وما فهمته انه
الجيش وغير جيش هناك مخطوفين ونحن تحدثنا
عن
مخطوفين نح نجلس في النمر النمر عربه
النمر وايضا تتحدثوا عن اسماء المخطوفين
وفي المنتصف جيش الدفاع يحارب ومن ان نذكر
ان نتحدث عن الانتعاش ونعود الى البيت
ايضا الزملاء الدين يريدون ان ينتعش هناك
اشخاص تحت الارض ولا يمكنهم الانتعاش ولا
يرون امهاتهم ونحن هنا نبقى
و المحلل العسكري
سؤال ليس الجميع
يذكر انا مسرور انا انك بشكل جيد وقبل عره
اشهر
عندما ايضا عندما تحدثت في
خطاب امام الرئيس وتحدثت عن
محاربين ايضا كانوا هناك في فتره الاعداد
وايضا رفعت اسرائيل دوله اسرائيل وايضا
كنت شابا في وحده جولاني وكنت محاربا وبعد
ان حارت في قطاع غزه هل هناك مفاهيم اخرى
بعد ما مررت به
هناك عرفت ان هذا السؤال
سياتي
وسفي
وسروري بسبب هذه الحرب التي فرضت علينا
وكان لي
من شرفي وسروري ان ارى هذه الرؤيه ان
تتحقق
رؤيه اذا كان نتحدث عن دوريه جولاني
يحاربون
وكوده وايضا هناك وحده مدرعات ووحده هندسه
ويضا كتيبه 53 وهم ابطال اسرائيل ويضحون
بانفسهم يوما بيوم وايضا كتيبه هندسه 149
اباء لاولاد وايضا نحن جميعا كتفا بكتف ض
العدوس ابناء الع وابناء الار جميعا
يعملون بعد وهذه رؤيه اننا تحت تحت سقف
واحد هذه قوه كبيره قوه المجتمع في
اسرائيل الجميع هنا يصمتون الى جنبي
ويقولون كم هو بطل شكرا انك تحدثت معنا
حافظ على
نفسك